c'erano una volta un uomo gay due uomini
etero pianti chi spende che per
facilitarci chiameremo lo stronzo e
l'amia spa teresa un avvocato non
biodegradabile e saverio l'autista per
taveri o abbracciata dal mar ionio e
dalle ceneri vulcaniche dell'etna
catania è un piccolo tesoro l'amico che
sa di mare incenso e vene ostruite da
piazza duomo al palazzo biscari fino al
mercato del pesce catania un melting pot
tra cultura e tradizione popolare e
intere famiglie che viaggiano in cinque
in vespa senza casco che siano le sue
ceramiche o la sua cucina tipica non c'è
un singolo frammento che non parli di
esperienze tradizione ubicata al sud di
messina con la quale si litiga il
primato della gremita e al nord di
siracusa alla quale ancora non riesce a
perdonare iniezione dei 476 avanti
cristo ed eterna scola rispetto al
capoluogo palermo con la quale si sa
essere in corso uno stop a una circa il
genere dell'arancina catania e liga da
mesi si distinguono quindi per carattere
docile e il poco rancore nei confronti
del resto della regione
miracolo architettonico e naturale ha
dato i natali a personaggi come carmen
consoli fiorello e pò baudo milia
milione ma soprattutto fabrizio corona
infine catania è la città che tra il
dire e il fare a di mezzo il mare
signore e signori
solo per voi catania
posto nostro stomaco era
arrivato il momento di rischiare la vita
senza pensate che state facendo
spunta spunta andrà che ha messo a far
bagno provando a dare
l'ultima parte del blog ma non potevamo
subire cavagna sia perché un posto
stupendo ma perché abbiamo abitato il
nostro cuore qua dentro ci troviamo
davanti al mare ad acitrezza che ce la
sta imballando gianmarco vuole e qui c'è
anche scusa nel vostro cuore sono esatto
nostro cugino ci farà da guida turistica
ospito e ci ospita anche essere una
puntata un pochino diversa dal solito
panorama del mare
[Risate]
e bellissimo il mare campagna sarà
bellissima da vedere ma io però a
mangiare esatto branca
prima guida turisti e dice andiamo a
mangiare
[Musica]
che è presidente il nostro bar di
fiducia ogni volta che veniamo al mare
ad acitrezza qualora ci fossero dei
dubbi a riguardo questa è la granita non
questa o questa bank è mai questa questa
questa è la granita sì quella il real
bundle tu che ci hai cioccolato e
questa è la brioche non questa o ancora
peggio questa odio me ne scampi e liberi
questa e si mangia insieme alla gremita
che questa non quest'acqua labbra che
questa non questa buon appetito ragazzi
parlate con una tecnica diverse la mia è
questa
ma è uno scempio questo euro e poi non
si scioglie che fa ma è inverno e
bellissimo questa di base e così
tu che si trovano quale la tecnica è
questa intesa non me lo sentivo che se
nascevo come si parla la verità
come si fa
[Musica]
villa bellini real si è posto bellissimo
siamo abituati a venirci d'estate è più
bella quando è più in fiore totti in
burton sacco di artisti che si sentiva
guerra
[Risate]
gli alberi quando sono stati tentati ma
che cazzo ne so
famoso personaggio della storia catanese
è sicuramente davy jones comandante
dell'olandese volante vede che siete il
posto erano del posto ed è morto
seppi pista piccoli
6 tutto che a tutti manca il naso
ma quanto è bello clima che cos'è un
chiostro sai come te frasi cavi qua
sotto a dice se c'era un potere
la pioggia che veniva da sotto quella
che ti punge quella grossa grossa che ti
a macchina forrest gump certo regala
quanto sono realistici gli uccelli su
quelle statue
famiglia non c'è mai uno solo quando
vengo in questi posti registrando
comunque un bene veri anche la luce del
sole dio ma detto
questo discorso non sognate noi non
sognate mai
bello sai giorno andiamo
dai gianni abbiamo visto
[Musica]
ma
dimostrazione della superiori catanese
girati cosa vi 17 dicembre 2000 21
giorni oggi che giorno 17 dicembre scuse
per 18 che fanno ogni giorno a
mezzanotte vengono qui e cambiano il
loro io penso crescesse
mamma mia ma portati via giovane
perdiamo ci pensi mi si piantano lotto
di crescere se mi facesse futuro
italiano tipo che ne so che un 8 in un
nome esatto lo possono fare solo con 89
con 6 e 5
fissati ragazzi villa bellini hanno
paura di perdersi il secondo il giorno
lì c'è un giardiniere anche a 20 qualche
segnala l'anas e quanto sarebbe bello
giovanni se questa fosse casa tua
abbiamo
e non vorrei allarmare nessuno ma è
circa mezz'ora che non mangiavano
lasciano un po preoccupata
pazzesco come spiego
l'arancino siete del team che il genere
del vostro arancino invece preferisce
share
andate a palermo questo preferisce kim
per i professionisti l'arancino lo
mangiano così e così rimane nella mano
la fine non è tipo troppo alto e non
riesce a nessuno basta ios e largo
riesco a prenderlo sempre da mancino
come è fatto tutte le imparato da fuori
io e cassone so
oggi ti sei svegliato che lo mangi così
tanto però sempre se io mangio per prima
è la cosa che mi piace di più che il
colino sopra oppure a me piaceva non può
più cioè di che stava parlando o vedi
tu ti sei sfondato tutto iii sentenza è
pregato del del blog di tutto quel
piatto di di rosticceria in silenzio da
15 minuti cosa era questo una cartuccia
[Musica]
lorenzo vorrei lorenzo insigne no no no
no no è napoletano
e meglio
dell'arco di milano
e mentre il teatro è meglio del colosseo
noi l'abbiamo voluto tenere sotto terra
per dire la
vittima sotto tutte le case è altissimo
incredibile ma che ne pensi di milano e
dice di catania che sia la milano del
sud per me è un insulto
siamo
una linea sempre ferita a catania perché
a questo lo sai che operi sono state
fatte in quell'anfiteatro tu che sei di
qui lo devo sapere io ragazze possiamo
fare il trenino no ti prego ma chissà
caporale sul trenino così accordarci
guardate quanta carino e tra un po del
sud per un camminare e bruciare tutto
quello che siamo mangia quotiamo no si
ricordi rimani solo tu
[Musica]
no
castello prima si trova sul mare
l'eruzione del
1600 che cazzo dei suoi la lava la
coperta lo ha coperto però è arrivata
fino a qua e ha allungato diciamo la
linea di costa e quelli adesso sta nel
centro della città
[Musica]
appena sentito la guida in inglese
diceva quella in place tascusì dare a
chi dà merito
oggi sei qui o no prossimi di outside
the job city con tale akita marina
hascisc ott fitch ai ragazzi vengono
fatto il giro più soporifero quel
trenino era tutto traballante con le
voci di sottofondo
e nova bello ne so io ho dormito
ne vorrei un altro giro si possa portare
un cuscino anche se mi paga siamo lì tre
di un mercatino natalizio vero già un
oggetto completamente se non resterà
molto bravo perché passava in mezzo a
roba impervia affatto filo proprio a
venti macchine ottimo guidato forse una
presa
buon record comunque
momento che hai un fetish per la
preoccupazione è nato molto tranquillo
non avere paura fa più inquietudine
ora è tranquillo non ti preoccupare
babbo anche quest'anno ce l'ha
[Musica]
io vengo a catania da 34 anni teatro
bellini quanti adro in denim sono mai
cacciato non l'ho mai visto con un mese
ho mai riso volta è una cosa assurda
bellissima est bellissimo
[Musica]
fase importantissima è l'elefante
catania piazza duomo c'è questa specie
di obelisco con un levantino alla base
il simbolo di catania e del siciliano
elefante si dice di oggi complimenti
perché si dice di oggi cioè qual è
l'origine da dove vieni qual è la radice
che cazzo ne so io qual è la radice di
no perché l'elefante di catania si
chiama agli occhi la storia
dell'elefante di lava e un mistero a
partire dal suono negli otto appunto lo
si fa derivare da una storpiatura del
nome eliodoro divenuto poi in dialetto
new york pare che questo giovane nobile
siciliano non essendo riuscito
nell'intento di essere nominato vescovo
abbia per ripicca studiato l'arte della
magia gli odori 8 etico capito o d'oro
onde d'oro hold con modo che l'europa
per tutti
[Musica]
finalmente all'ultima puntata del blog
ma se riuscirà a trovare il natale se
questo non è natale non so cos'altro si
sa è la chiamo cilla aspetta un attimo
ma vogliono da isidoro
fermi
ma se vuole fare andare da isidoro
eni riposa che siamo ragazzi un tenerone
[Musica]
prendi ragazza non me la farò vedere a
mettere come va bene quando vuoi
sicuramente faccio così un 3 che guarda
un po con questo un documento da
infilarsi precisato decisione ragazzo
qualcuno un'altra sfida abu dhabi prima
fa i tappi e poi partì con le lattine
mamma
[Musica]
prima lei le ho prese tutte con la
posizione quale serviva l'occhio
ma se fate le riprese da arrivano questi
diventata veramente molto bene ma in
maniera così stracciante poi è
un'esperienza pazzesca chi ha vinto fra
i due secondo considerando entrambe le
partite
da professionista del settore
[Musica]
a quello unicorno rosa lo gradirei molto
non fare la timida come palle da
bravo a sparare bravissima
unico per pietà stima
quella pistola un cecchino gian marco
sei bravo cosa s'è visto secondo te la
mette tutta mio papà mi aveva mandato il
video dell'alluvione terribile
certo punto è passati da una specie di
ambulanza acquatica che si stava
stringendo il cuore perché ha fatto dei
danni assurdi però non sembra che ci sia
stato guardando insomma le stesse aree
del video gr piccolo pensavo che questo
è possibile un ingresso della corte dei
miracoli di catania le foglie e poi le
tartarughe ninja questo qui è uno dei
posti che più mi terrorizzavano e odiato
da piccolo che fanno tutto il mercato
proprio del pesce del pesce ma anche di
alcuni è un mercato fanno urlano tutto
il terre da piccola mi terrorizzava la
gente mi urlava che adesso non ho voglia
integrazione sociale
[Musica]
non volevamo stare semplicemente col
nostro driver io abbiamo aggiunto anche
il nostro cugino paolo che è venuto a
raggiungerci e stato veramente bravo ci
puoi salutare vuol dire grazie a tutti a
rivedere
io sono finito con saverio che comunque
anche noi la follia però gianmarco e ti
do un paolo che sono due super nonno
genito l'ultimo nome
lavigne fila con il mio
non mi interessa
[Musica]
non hai commentato
non ho sparato quell'elefante posso
sbagliarmi che salta voce come il primo
per dire sono
non posso nemmeno disegno a tutti
si macchiano
la prima che mi la cassa si appresti
a casa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho stravolto
quindi ti rispondo come era a cena
con la compagnia qual è il migliore del
tavolo tutti si ubriaca per continua
giorni stiamo andando a bere per il
bellissimo questo gioco che stiamo
andando a castello
buon natale buon natale ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto perché è stato un
bel momento e sono molto nel corpo e
cerca di fare qualcosa di diverso io ho
sempre mangiato noi mangiamo sempre che
il caso è diverso solo cibo se stato
girato l'italia abbiamo avuto la
possibilità di incontrare le persone
anche di scoprire delle cose che non
consigliato in altri tomasig o di gusto
io non ce la facevo non sono regolari di
stomaco ogni giorno sto partorendo
pinocchio guarda e mi dice papà ed è
così che questa puntata del blocco
finisce qui tra i dazi rari e regini
mascoli perché se mou catanesi e tanti
in mare per voi che avete avuto le palle
di resistere fino a questo punto grazie
ragazzi avete stomaco da venne adesso
però uscite scopate divertiti e se vi
vanno bene fatto un po di pubblicità il
blog ma finisce qui
ma come sempre
buon natale
grazie
[Musica]